wow wow ich kann nicht eine ahnung das
ist komplett neuer geschmack für mich
gerade wo ich gut so marc anthonys
erdbeeren zitronen torten aber das ist
so was ist ganz neues
[Musik]
heim zu sammeln wir machen heute eine
hippies kuss blüten torte und wer bis
heute noch nicht mit frischen
hibiskusblüten gebacken habe der sollte
das wirklich ganz schnell nach und ich
habe das nämlich im august für meine
schwester zum geburtstag gab es eine
richtig schöne hibiskusblüten torte
gebacken euch auf instagram mitgenommen
und ihr habt ja nach dem rezept gefragt
dass jetzt endlich geschafft das mal
gerne vorzunehmen abzugeben und ich muss
sagen ich bin echt krass war bis kurz
bluten wenn man die so wie ich jetzt
natürlich getrocknet riechen sie erst
mal gar nicht so intensiv aber sobald
die sie da verarbeitet oder kocht kommt
das volle aroma raus und ihr diskus
nötig sind super gesund wenn sie zum
beispiel als tee auf voller vitamin c
voller antioxidantien und mag ich
persönlich sehr gerne freuen weil er
auch so süß schmeckt und ich meine jetzt
aber folgendes wir backen jetzt einen
bizkit boden das ist zwar mein standard
bis geboren ich habe auch ein basic
rezept in kick-ass buck schule also hier
auf einem kanal aber ich möchte euch das
gerne hier nochmal zeigen weil ich die
hibiskusblüten jetzt nicht nur die creme
und in die deko verarbeitet sondern
gleich auch direkt in den biss geboten
und daneben steht einfach die blüten und
gibt sich hier in meinem mörser und da
könnt ihr damit das einfach so ein
bisschen besser klappt das schon mal ein
bisschen was hier vom zucker nehme ich
habe mir schon alles abgewogen schreibe
euch alle ganz genauen mengen an ganz
unten in der box ein bisschen was von
zucker rein und dann einfach schön fein
börsen
[Musik]
so wie hibiskus blüten haben wir dann so
vorbereitet und jetzt gehts eigentlich
weiter mit unserem bizkit boden dafür
brauchen wir ja ich mache das ganze in
der küchenmaschine ihr könnt eure
handrührgerät verwenden wichtig ist
jetzt dass wir die eier schön sauber
voneinander trennen das heißt ist darf
nichts aber auch gar nichts vom eigelb
ins eiweiß rein und wenn doch was drüber
holt dann nimmt es auch raus weil sonst
wird es nicht funktionieren dass ihr
euer eiweiß steif schlagen könnt dann
gebe ich gleich auch schon die hälfte
des übriggebliebenen zuckers hiermit zur
eiweiß masse da darf dann auch gern noch
eine prise salz dazu die eben noch mal
den süßen geschmack und dann schlage ich
das zu einer schönen baiser masse
[Musik]
so die bw masse ist fertig alles ist
schön stark das kommt das ganze bis zur
seite jetzt nehme ich einfach den
gleichen schneebesen aufsatz das
speichern wir gerne das spülen und jetzt
kommt hier einfach noch der restliche
zucker zum ein gelb das wird dann
richtig schön dick cremig es wird auch
viel heller sogar richtig schön
aufgeschlagen und da gibt ihr unbedingt
von den extrazug in die verbindung
zwischen vanille extrakt und
hibiskusblüten ist einfach ein traum und
dann gerne auf maximaler geschwindigkeit
zu 34 minuten geschlagen und dann geht
es weiter
[Musik]
jetzt ist auch die eine masse richtig
schön cremig genauso wie wir sie haben
möchten und jetzt brauchen wir einen
teig schon jetzt geht es nicht mehr
weiter mit der maschine da brauchen wir
jetzt einfach nur viel geduld ein
bisschen liebe wie ich immer so schön
sagt aber es ist wirklich so warum ist
das wirklich ganz vorsichtig hier die
b&c masse und hd eigelb masse heben und
zwar immerhin so bewegungen als wird ihr
von außen nach innen streichen und
irgendwann verbindet sich davon dann
macht ihr weiter ist nichts mehr übrig
ist von der masse
[Musik]
als nächstes kommen die trockenen
zutaten hinein das sind einmal mehr
speisestärke und backpulver und jetzt
ist ganz ganz wichtig dass wir das 7
denn das ist wirklich eine sehr feine
masse und ich möchte ja nicht dass da
irgendwie klümpchen oder so noch drin
sind und ihr dürft das auch gerne in
mehreren schritten unterheben ich gebe
zwar alles in ein sieb rhein wurde ich
gleich auch die restaurants ich sie
immer nur sohn christian und dann unter
rühren und dann wieder weiter 7 und ganz
zum schluss kommen noch die
vorbereiteten hibiskusblüten dazu
[Musik]
den fertigen boden geben wir dann in
eine 26 cm springform gerne backpapier
auskleiden schön glatt streichen und
dann bei 180 grad im vorgeheizten
backofen für 20 minuten backen mehr
brauche auch gar nicht und anschließend
zugedeckt am besten vollständig
auskühlen lassen und wir kümmern uns in
der zwischenzeit um die diskus blüten
cremen dafür müssen wir etwas
vorbereiten wir nehmen uns einfach eine
kleine fahne oder eintopf geben
hibiskusblüten wasser und zucker
reinlassen das aufkochen und dann darf
das fünf minuten lang köcheln dann wird
es quasi so ein richtig intensiver sirup
dem wir dann einmal nur durch ein sieb
geben ein bisschen noch drücken damit
alles rauskommt und dann habe ich das
jetzt fünf minuten lang im kühlschrank
abkühlen lassen und man glaubt gar nicht
wie viel geschmack in so ein bisschen
zielgruppe drin ist es wirklich die
ganze klima romantisieren natürlich
kommt auch vanille zum einen findet ihr
bis kosten und vanille perfekte kombi so
ich starte jetzt hier mit der creme
dafür habe ich hier wieder die
küchenmaschine wie immer könnt ihr auch
ein handrührgerät verwenden einfach nur
ein bisschen länger schlagen und da gebe
ich jetzt zuallererst mascarpone bei mir
sind jetzt alle zutaten ganz kalt aus
dem kühlschrank da gebe ich jetzt zuerst
mal rein das schöne ist bei mascarpone
jetzt im gegensatz zu quark ist dass die
einfach so neutraler schmeckt und nicht
so einen sauren beigeschmack hat und das
passt einfach gleich noch mit dem sirup
ist passt perfekt weil das die den
geschmack total aufnimmt ja wohl alles
daneben schmeißen hier aber nicht so
schön da gebe ich jetzt gleich auch noch
die sahne dazu wann in der extrakt und
dann fand ich anders so langsam zu
schlagen so dass es sich verbindet geht
dann immer höher mit der geschwindigkeit
und schlag ist dann komplett steif und
lasse dann während des noch seine fest
und hibiskus blüten sirup ein riese
[Musik]
und fertig ist unsere hibiskusblüten
creme das ganze dauert wirklich nicht
lange dadurch dass wir wirklich alles
auf einmal schlagen und die zutaten
wirklich nur nach und nach dazu geben
achtet darauf dass ihr nicht zu lange
schlag damit die creme nicht gewinnt
gibt das jetzt mal kurz zur seite und
mache weiter mit meinem kuchen boden der
ist inzwischen abgekühlt dann einfach
hier von der springform lösen ich teile
den diesmal nur einmal durch der ist
nämlich nicht sehr hoch ich habe das
bewusst so gemacht ich wollte nämlich
relativ viel creme dies ist sehr lecker
die bühne natürlich auch aber relativ
viel creme in kombination zum boden
daher schaltet den nur einmal durch dann
suche ich mir die hübsche tortenplatte
aus und dann werde ich schon anfangen zu
schichten aber behaltet euch definitiv
so circa aber fast ein drittel beiseite
für die deko ein bisschen weniger als
ein drittel
[Musik]
nachdem die torte da rundherum auch noch
eingestrichen habt könnt ihr die
restliche creme einfach in einen
spritzbeutel füllen ich habe jetzt hier
vorne die 200.000 oder dran ich verlinke
euch alles gerne in die infobox und
jetzt könnt ihr eure torte auch schon
einteilen können zwölf stücke nehmen
oder 40 gb 12 liegt jetzt einfach in
meinem torten einteilen da oben rein
weil dann könnt ihr auch besser
dekorieren dann wissen mich wo ihr die
rosen auf spritzen können sagt und dann
einfach mit dem mit der restlichen creme
wie gesagt dekorieren und was ich auch
noch gemacht habe für die deko damit
auch optisch so müssen nachher diskus
blüten torte aussieht einfach noch mal
so ein bisschen was malen zusammen mit
zucker und dann später einfach noch so
obendrüber geben
[Musik]
also ich weiß nicht was er sagt aber ich
finde dass die sich auf jeden fall sehen
lassen kann wird sie richtig so wenn ihr
die auf dem tisch stellt und dann kommt
besuch da denken wieso willst himbeeren
und sagte dann freien leute so etwas ist
das glaubt man kommt auf diskus erst
ganz zum schluss ich muss auf seine
gewinne bis kurs
toten allgemein oder rezepte und ich
finde das muss sich ändern das ist auf
jeden fall ein schöner neuer geschmack
haben sie das jetzt gerade im shop aber
wenn er zurückkomme werde ich auf jeden
fall den textes mit wählen weil ich sehr
gespannt bin auch seine reaktion denn
als ich dafür meine schwester gebacken
habt könnt ihr ja auch nicht probieren
ich verabschiede mich an der stelle und
wünsche euch ganz viel spaß beim
nachmachen und wenn euch das rezept
gefallen hat die last auf jeden fall
einen daumen nach oben und dann sehen
wir uns auch im nächsten rezept
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hallo willkommen zum test erst heute
haben wir spaß mit kuchen wir haben hier
eine rote kurve muss ist das eine
hibiskus blüten torrijos ok diskus
klingt lecker aus dem boden sind richtig
pfiffiger bis geboten mit hibiskus
briten und vanille wow wow wow nur was
anderes ne das ist so ich kann es nicht
in ordnung das ist komplett neuer
geschmack für mich gerade war echt gut
somit kenntnis erdbeeren zitronen torten
aber das ist so was gibt's neues seminar
sind komplett neuer geschmack also ich
find den boden sehr flüssig creme ist
top top also auch nicht so viel creme
ist so wenig weiß ja also ich bin
einfach das besondere ich habe ja auch
schon ein stück weg ge haben diese
fruchtige note aber mit wandel aber
nicht dieses fruchtige was man kennt von
diesem typischen hinweg worden weil es
was ich feiere das war überhaupt nicht
weiß dann zu fruchtig schmecken das ist
jetzt so effekt hat die richtige antwort
ist eines der leckersten traten hier
gemacht hat muss ich jetzt an der stelle
echt sagen das mega wirklich hansa und
auch sehr schön sieht sehr schön aus
danke
passend zum bald folgten heute
heute ist nämlich valentinstag er muss
mein geschenk wie falken waren sie sagt
ihr seid ganz ehrlich was sie von
karajan und ich kann nicht mehr sprechen
wie nehme ich jeden tag meinen gesagt
haben ja dann stürzt euch denken macht
spaß haben die händler aber scheiße nein
wir haben wirklich sagt weil ich seit
meiner frau jeden tag liebe und das
wichtigste um nicht an einem besonderen
tag liebt eure fahrer jeden tag egal war
ob welches tag ob diese februar oder 30
die februar das ist mein statement
gewesen
ich muss jetzt eigentlich mal darauf
installieren so tickt doch lange so das
ist so wertvoll den satz rausgehauen
kann hier hatte ja ja das ist häufig mal
auf die rampe ich das geld also leute
auf wiedersehen
[Musik]